i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
so the search continues for the believed
mar-a-lago trader slash mole slash
leaker whatever this is the story the
belief wherein
uh there are some in the maga right who
believe that the only way the fbi
could have known where to look and what
to do during this search warrant would
have been if there were some mole within
magaland and many names have been
floated everything from some secret
service agent to some employee at
mar-a-lago all the way to mark meadows
now i don't know for sure that it's
clear there is such a mall because there
are also claims
that donald trump personally gave fbi
agents a tour of mar-a-lago some months
ago and might even have shown them
exactly where everything is we just
don't know if there is a so-called mole
at mar-a-lago but increasingly there are
reports that donald trump is being
driven nuts that's a quote driven nuts
not knowing who the mole is according to
an ex-federal prosecutor and others have
made similar claims and one of the
things that is being made very very
clear by donald trump's lawyer alina
habba
is that
they're going to find who the mole is
they're going to figure out who it is
and then all bets are off another one of
these thinly veiled threats
take a listen to alina habba appearing
on
i believe this is on newsmax and it's
the typical mob speak that we've become
very accustomed to in the trump era the
president's position the same as what i
would advise him is to
ask them to uncover everything so that
we can see what is going on i understand
the witness protection issue but at the
same time these witnesses are truly not
going to be um
concealed for very long that's just not
the nature of the doj and the fbi
they're gonna figure out who you are
eventually this is the typical
mob speak that we've gotten accustomed
to
from trumpists this is either
just more insanity
or
a warning a threat
to the informant if they even exist how
are they supposed listen
alina habba wants to know how do we
intimidate a witness when we don't know
who the witness is we need to be told
who that witness is and there is no
question whatsoever that if there is
such a mole and if indeed their identity
becomes public that the mega trump right
is going to go absolutely nuts i mean
listen they're going after fbi agents
merrick garland is receiving death
threats christopher wray who was
selected to run the fbi by trump who
signed off on the search warrant
uh he is getting death threats these
people are vicious these people are
violent january 6th prove that to us and
so i understand the concern if such a
mole exists i understand why they would
rather not be known and everybody is in
maga world is melting down and that's
what i want to talk about next we
haven't even had time for these clips
this week because it's been so busy
donald trump jr suffered a complete and
total meltdown over the fbi search
warrant that was served at mar-a-lago
there are actually dozens of clips of
don jr that have floated around over the
last week but i'm going to look at one
specific clip with you this one is of
junior
sped up as he always is and
the the hypothesis has been this guy's
on uppers
and whether he is or isn't drug
addiction is not funny that's we're
talking about a disease
but even for his own standards he is
particularly hopped up and incoherent
during this viral video which got a
million and a half views
see if you can follow any of what he's
even saying here uh my father says that
he would have given them what they
wanted had they done this but no they
needed the fbi hostage rescue team the
hrt their elite tactical unit
and 30-something agents to show up to my
father's home where they then wouldn't
allow or didn't want any lawyer's
presence if you're not watching
the facial expressions are bizarre
the hand motions are frenetic because
i'm sure given all of the examples of
totally above board stuff that the fbi
does that's totally great right like i
don't know if i'm the fbi you want
someone's lawyer there so that there can
be no other claims later on but you know
honestly they don't care
at this point like given all of the
things that they seem to have fabricated
or lied about and all of these things
guess what folks there's exactly zero
equal justice under the law you know
what
pro tip for life this is an ultimate
life hack become a democrat then you can
do whatever you want with no
accountability this guy is out of his
mind
no law legal action they'll just leave
you alone okay but you needed the hrt to
exercise this warrant at mar-a-lago give
me a break right again hillary completes
30 000 emails and takes
and i actually don't know at this point
when they say bleaching emails
uh
this all started because trump seemed to
think
that
i don't even know if i could explain it
trump seemed to think that
there was a there was like software
called i believe the software is called
acid wash and trump at one point
genuinely believed that hillary clinton
was acid washing hard drives like you
would do to a pair of jeans like it was
popular in the late 80s early 90s acid
washing and now it's grown to where they
talk about bleaching emails they haven't
said they've oxicleaned them but that
would be the next thing i genuinely
can't tell
what they believe about whether literal
bleach is being used hammers two phones
nothing shady about this folks but
trump's hammering phones that's just the
best memory imagine bill opens the door
to the basement and hillary's in there
with a mallet just destroying phones
cooperate and they still have to show up
this way you know why
because they're there to intimidate you
they're acting
like the fascists
we've been seeing them
be
and of course the fascism is on the
right last few years folks and for all
the democrat talk about republicans
being fascists
these are the guys acting like it give
me a break
okay they wouldn't look at hunter and
deals in china or ukraine or links to
russian oligarchs with links to putin or
links to human trafficking and literally
videotaped evidence of him saying that
the russian mob may have his laptop no
no that was russian disinformation but
we need the hrt team to go to mar-a-lago
it's intimidation folks and the number
one thing we can do to save america and
prevent
us from becoming the dictatorship that
these guys would like is to drain the
swamp and fire all of the bureaucrats
imagine thinking after everything that's
happened over the last six years at this
point
that
trump is the person who's going to be
draining the swamp
you you would have to be
in a fantasy world to be able to believe
that so there's the latest from junior
another one of these hopped up bizarre
rants
and it didn't look too much better for
eric trump which we will talk about next
so eric trump not known as the smartest
of the trump children
he now uh made the claim that the
raid as he calls it on trump's
mar-a-lago
will lead to a terrorist attack the
logic there is because 30 agents were at
mar-a-lago last monday
then some terrorist attack won't be
prevented because everybody's too busy
it's a very very strange thing i missed
this when he gave this interview take a
look this doesn't happen i know greg i
know this apparatus very well as you do
this does not happen without
presidential consent you know the white
house new mark my word they're out there
today saying that no one in the white
house knew this was a hundred percent
mark my word directed by the white house
this is a
political hit on my father
uh they know biden's floundering the
polls he's doing absolutely horrible and
so what did they do they put on a stunt
like this and you know i want everybody
to remember god forbid i hate having to
say this but if there's ever another
terrorist attack in this country if
there's ever another school shooting in
this country the next time you see a
serial killer in this country
i want everybody to remember that the
fbi
spent all their resources going into
mar-a-lago to look for
you know effectively records for a
public library right you know right
imagine a trump library everything would
be written in crayon other than being
focused on china who's ripping off
america every single day rather than
being focused on the threats that plague
this country terrorism that wants to
come in here al qaeda you know
the taliban so many other people who
want to destroy our way of life
extremists who want to destroy our way
of life
the fbi because of joe biden and because
of this incompetent administration has
weaponized the system there's no
evidence biden had anything to do with
it
to go after their political rivals
and that's their priority versus keeping
this country safe i want everybody to
remember that because you better believe
we're going to see one of these
instances again
and it's going to be because their eye
was off the ball
that is a devastating way to put it i
hadn't thought about it that way and
you're absolutely right yeah the fbi is
known for despite having 35 000
employees the fbi only works on one case
at a time famous the fb they literally
all the field offices across the country
35 000 employees one case at a time and
because they spent a few hours at
mar-a-lago
terrorism will now not be stopped these
people are nuts and they're dangerous
but unfortunately their followers hear
these talking points and they just
repeat them uncritically
let me know what you think find me on
twitter at dpakman tomorrow we will be
joined by producer pat who will be
hosting the show the next couple days
then farron cousins from ring of fire
will be hosting a couple days after that
and then i will be back with stories of
peace and love also remember that
wednesday august 31st at 6 pm we will
have the members only david pakman show
town hall
this is a town hall like the others
we've done
except it will be open only to members
don't worry we're going to get back to
the wide open town halls as well we're
just doing one
members only town hall i would love for
you to participate and you can do so
simply by being a member at
joinpacman.com
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com pacman you
will get aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below
the david pakman show is of course an
audience supported program you can sign
up at joinpacman.com
to become a member get instant access to
the bonus show and other benefits
including members only town halls the
next of which will be wednesday august
31st
at 6 p.m
eastern time which is going to be
tremendous
let's hear from people in the audience
on this slightly early friday type show
because the week is a little bit
different this week we take calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord and we're going to start today
with alex from california alex welcome
what's on your mind today
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
nice so
when it comes to like elections and how
people vote it really seems like it
comes down to
the economy than anything else like
um you could have things like roe v wade
or like gay marriage be overturned but
if there's like a recession in that same
year it feels like they'll vote on the
like recession and say oh democrats
uh ruin the economy who cares about um
these like um civil rights issues yeah
what do you think about that i
completely agree
the perception of how the economy is
doing even if number one
people's perception is wrong
and number two
it doesn't really have much to do with
the president
both
are
um
hugely influential in how people vote
and this is why things are suddenly
looking much better for democrats even
though i don't think it really has much
to do with joe biden there was this
blockbuster jobs report in july wages
are up inflation's down gas prices are
down et cetera it has very little to do
with joe biden but it seems to be
helping democrats very much in terms of
the outlook for november so yes it's the
economy stupid was the phrase james
carville came up with and it uh it is
more like it is the perception of the
economy regardless of whether it's
accurate
okay so let's say um i've been here a
lot of like recession warnings coming up
they say there's going to be like a
recession in like 2024 let's say there
is
so
is is that going to be the determining
factor whether or not like joe biden
loses the election even though like
democrat uh the republican agenda is
like has really awful things like
to like to do or or want to do
sorry
i don't know you're saying if there is a
recession or you're saying there won't
be one yeah no i'm saying if there is a
recession that's pretty much a
guaranteed loss for like joe biden if he
if he decides to run yeah i think if at
the time if i think if joe biden runs
for reelection and there is a very clear
recession in september and october of
2024 i think biden definitely loses
that's so far off and remember people
have been predicting imminent recession
since 2015
and it hasn't really happened i mean you
could argue technically we just were in
one because
gdp went down very very slightly last
quarter but when you look at every other
indicator it's really hard to make that
case but let's wait and see i agree with
you though if there is really a
recession it's going to be bad for joe
biden if he's on the on the ticket
all right that's it devin thank you for
taking my call thank you appreciate it
uh very very good questions
let's go next to
um let's go to jack from
minnesota jack welcome
hey david um how are you doing i'm doing
well
uh so
i've been kind of wondering this all my
my entire political uh
you know since i've gotten into politics
i
how genuine are some of the the people
on the right because you have people
like ben shapiro who's harvard grad uh
etc etc he should know that he is lying
to his audiences uh you know every day
or
or is there a possibility that he just
believes the things he believes in
well i think it depends on which issue i
mean i think that there's probably
some areas where there's a genuine
belief in some areas where there's like
a knowing exaggeration i think it's an
issue by issue thing
okay per yeah um
because i've just been wondering because
i'm i i just genuinely don't know if
there's method in the madness of
of some of these people
yeah it's you know i think it's for me
it's more interesting rather than the
media people it's more interesting like
when when you see interviews at a trump
rally
and the people just parrot all the same
stuff that these people say like oh the
election was stolen and the raid was
illegal and benghazi and hillary and
obama gay and all this stuff like do
they remember do they even know that
they're being
you know grifted and lied to or are they
genuine believers that's a more
difficult question to answer to me and
also a more interesting one
okay yeah it is um
i guess that's all thank you for taking
my call all right thanks jack jack from
minnesota with a beautiful question
let's go next to jwr from atlanta
welcome jwr
um welcome i'm hot up thanks for having
me dave how am i how am i coming in as
far as like the sound is it too rough or
whatnot or it's okay i think it's
definitely doable
um i don't know if you've covered this
on your show before but what is your
take on the um
okay so in the polls it appears it
appears that work that rafael warnock
has uh has not a sizable but a lead over
hershel walker
but then you but then there but then
there seems to be but then you look over
at the governor's race and it at best
pierce appears to be very close between
uh
between stacey abrams and brian kemp i
just wanted to hear your thoughts on the
um
your thoughts on like the possible
ticket splitting going on here and what
you think the explanation for that might
be that's a good question i don't i
don't know enough about so okay the way
these polls are typically done
is people are asked how likely are you
to vote and who do you plan to vote for
how strong is your support for that
person are you a 100 in for this person
or are you leaning that way or whatever
and then you kind of blend it and you
get a final polling number now
intuitively if we're talking about
georgia voters and you go to georgia
voters and you poll them about the kemp
abrams race and you pulled them about
the war knock walker race it it's both
are totally statewide races so everybody
in the state is allowed to vote if you
have a difference it means one of two
things
some people plan to vote in one of those
races and not the other that would be
one reason right you plan to go and vote
for the governor's race and just leave
blank the senate or you plan to vote for
different parties you might vote for
brian kemp the republican for the
gubernatorial but then for
rafael warnock the democrat in the
senate race which also seems kind of
weird and counter-intuitive so i i
actually don't know why you you would
imagine that you would have almost
identical numbers now there's a there's
a counterpoint to that
incumbency stacey abrams is the
challenger raphael warnock is the
incumbent so to some degree you might
have people who are only marginally
patent paying attention who are just
leaning towards the person who's
currently in that office and that may be
a reason why we see different numbers
but it is sort of weird and
counterintuitive
right although
although it could possibly speak volumes
of speak volumes about the fact that
herschel that that herschel walker is
was
well i won't i won't say a weak
candidate but not maybe as strong as
some would have expected possibly
yeah i mean that's possible i i it would
be this would be a great question for a
polling expert i feel like that we
should have on and actually ask
specifically what explains this
right i only asked this because like um
i i'm up i'm a pulp i'm the pole worker
at full at fulton county and like i
i mean like i can't i i can't comment i
can't i can't comment in explicit detail
on these things but it is like an
interest it is like an interesting
phenomenon absolutely absolutely i'm
going to look for an expert to talk to
about this i think it is an interesting
uh issue
all right thank you all right jwr thank
you so much for the call very much
appreciate it let's go next to jen from
illinois jen welcome to the show
jen from illinois welcome you're on the
air
and jen from illinois last opportunity
you are on the air
and jen is gone that's truly a shame
it's really a shame that that uh that
that happened
let's go to andrew from brooklyn andrew
welcome
hi david
can you hear me yes i can
hey so i was talking with some friends
the other day we're talking about the j6
uh hearings and so forth and they're not
right-wing they're not left-wing they're
progressive so on and so forth and they
felt like actually maybe wait hold on a
second
let me just see if you're saying the
people you were talking to aren't
right-wing or left-wing they are
progressive isn't progressive the same
as left-wing
yes correct so centrists i guess they
would call themselves i'm not really
sure what they call it wait they are or
they are not progressives
i i don't remember but they don't
consider themselves either democrat or
republican
okay all right go on uh they're an
interracial
they're an interracial couple
um
my friend nicole's had had had an
abortion
and but as far as j6 is concerned they
were saying you know maybe we should you
know overthrow our government or at
least overhaul it i mean it has so many
and not in the way it was done on j6
obviously but what's your feeling i mean
do we need like a complete overhaul of
the government the u.s government
uh
no i don't think so i mean it depends on
what you have in mind i think there's a
lot of problems that i would try to
solve like for example i think we should
have a national popular vote vote rather
than an electoral college i just don't
think an overthrow is going to achieve
that because
of the framework that exists legally in
in the country uh i i'm not sure i mean
i think
i
almost anyone would agree that there are
things that need to be fixed and
repaired
but that an overthrow of the government
is unlikely to achieve that
right well i actually meant overhaul not
overthrow yeah sure there's lots of
things that need to be overhauled we
need to overhaul how health insurance is
organized in the country we need to
overhaul how we do elections overhaul
campaign finance there's tons of stuff
that needs to be a police reform and on
and on
but uh i i'm with you there we
definitely need an overhaul
yeah and i mean i i had uh terminal
brain cancer two brain surgeries which
i've talked about on your channel in the
chat and so forth and i mean my 500 000
you know medical bill uninsured the
medical system for sure needs an
overhaul again i'm saying overhaul not
overthrow i'm with you absolutely
absolutely need an overhaul right
so i'm i'm i i just want you know i
really appreciate your show and that
jack broke the rules and asked you how
you're doing so i know i know that was
horrible that was horrible andrew thank
you for the call
all right brother all right take care
there's andrew from brooklyn wishing you
the best um let's go next to daniel from
nevada daniel welcome yes
hello uh can you hear me yes i can
awesome um i've been trying to catch you
for months
well here we are let's make it
worthwhile
oh so
in
recent years
so uh
uh there's big
stuff happening in in america and and
it's really bad but i feel like there's
stuff in other countries as well that
i i think needs more attention okay give
me an example um
so an example uh
my um
i only know about this because my best
friend was there so in the philippines
um there was this bill early this year
um
and the president led it lapsed into law
from 30 days of not finding it or
vetoing it
and it's called the social media or the
sim card and social media registration
act
and it
basically in in
the things it does is require
all
filipino citizens to one register their
legal name and id with a sim card if
they have it and daniel i hate to
interrupt you i just here's the thing i
want to say to you
for for the average american that's just
not a more important issue than the
domestic issues that we're dealing with
i don't i don't know about that issue
the registration of sim cards in the
philippines but it's not that's not like
my audience if i we do like a show about
here's issues facing the country
if i talk about that's not it's not more
important for people here it's just not
and i i don't deny that it's a relevant
issue
the
well but the second part is is the part
that's
like really bad it requires the whole
country to dox themselves on social
media right you can't you cannot use a
username you have to use your real name
on your social media account okay
basically doxing them under penalty of
law with a penalty of minimum six years
imprisonment or 200 000 pesos if that's
as you describe that sounds bad
but yeah from the perspective of the
united states where we've got a broken
health care system we're trying to
figure out how to prevent the rise of a
fascistic authoritarian maga right wing
we're trying to deal with all of these
different issues and and the environment
and all these different things
the fact that you've got to dox yourself
on social media in the philippines it's
i'm not saying that it's not important
to the people there but it's not really
an issue that in the u.s is going to get
a lot of attention
okay yeah it just it just is what it is
you know
all right my friend thank you for the
call i appreciate it there's always lots
of important issues
it's just not um
that i just don't know that that is like
the perfect example of the issue that's
being missed in american media
necessarily let's take a very quick
break
if you're holding to talk to me don't
hang up because we're going right back
to the phones in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
let's speak to some more people via the
david pakman show discord which you can
find at
davidpakman.com
discord we're going to go next to miles
in bay city michigan miles welcome
mr pacman can you hear me just barely if
you can speak up it would be great
okay so
uh does it still come in through a bit
that's a little bit better
so a quick question for you this is a
kind of
relevant to about employment because
there's
you know there's a lot of places where
it's like oh we can't find workers well
well most of these jobs they only offer
part-time i can't help but want to look
at some of these
managers and stuff and just like and
you're not offering full time and
benefits like i can't help but
ultimately look at some of these people
it's like instead of looking for say
five part-timers i hear three
full-timers
i can't help but feel like that in the
end it's like it's gonna cost the
business roughly the same but you can
have someone there to run the business
and all that and it should function as
intended
you know they'll get people to fill
those jobs if they
give you know you know they offer a
full-time job and benefits i mean i just
can't help but feel like that's just
when i see some of that stuff like that
it's just like the answer's right in
front of you and they're not taking it i
generally speaking agree i mean one of
the things about full employment and we
are really close to full employment i
know right wingers will say oh but
people filed for unemployment last month
that always happens but when you have
3.5 percent unemployment
the jobs report came in at double the
number of new jobs that was expected
we're we are close to full employment in
this country one of the things is
employers are going to have to fight for
employees to some degree particularly in
these minimum wage or close to minimum
wage jobs
um so yeah i think that that is
it
it's just supply and demand to a certain
degree
very interesting
but anyway that's just that was on my
mind all right thank you so much for the
call i appreciate it yeah this is a good
point and we're it's it's we're
experiencing it
um in some sectors but not in others and
it's because of what we might kind of
colloquially call the quality of the job
let's go next to jamie in south dakota
jamie you're on the air what's going on
hello david uh can you hear me okay yes
i can
okay
um i'm like kind of like a capitalist in
like the nordic kind of model sense okay
and i know you're from um argentina and
i was just wondering if you uh followed
like any of like the leftist uh
wins in like latin america
yes to some degree i followed them but
did you have a specific question about
one um i had a i was wondering if you'd
think like with their some of their talk
of like over like uh taking over like
the market economy
if uh like you think that they could
like
turn kind of like that like this
government would be different
than like the previous outcomes which
gov which government are you talking
about what country
um i don't know just kind of maybe like
chile specifically i don't know you're
saying if chile could overthrow
capitalism
or like
or like he's talking about like uh doing
different things to like get
um make it more kind of public and like
more like more socialist and get rid of
like the market-based stuff yeah listen
i mean
i think that'd be positive countries
should do
whatever the people want their elected
representatives to do
i'm not a socialist personally so i
wouldn't be advocating for a country to
become a socialist country
but if chile or whoever
if there's demand for it from the people
and it's not being imposed in an
authoritarian way by a you know
authoritarian of some kind
try it abs absolutely why not
right right yeah i'm just really
interested to see how it goes i'm not a
socialist personally but yeah i mean
listen give give it a go if that's what
the people want
right exactly yeah well thank you for
taking my call my pleasure you too jamie
from south dakota
uh great to hear from you
let's go next to
bodhi is it pronounced bodhi from new
orleans or body
yes it's it's bodhi from new orleans
thanks so much it's like from point
break patrick swayze yes uh your your
discord is already blinging so we're
kind of hanging by a thread here on
keeping you on but what's on your mind
today
hey david thanks so much for taking my
call i just recently watched um
an interview from
from the forward party from andrew yang
i wanted to ask but i don't really trust
that he and his coacher the former
republican governor from new jersey i
don't think they have a mind to bring it
to the presidency but they did talk
about focusing more on local elections
stuff like city councilman
local city politics so i wanted to ask
what you thought about not just support
party but about bringing american
politics more to local politics so
instead of just party affiliations like
democrat republican making maybe making
new parties or just voting for people
who are independents in that sense
100
on the local importance of local
elections
i have voted in different local
elections during my life in different
places i've lived which were
non-partisan elections people don't
declare a party
they doesn't mean they aren't democrats
or republicans or or whatever but they
don't declare a party and you actually
have to
hopefully figure out what they're about
i think that that's great as far as the
forward party we reviewed earlier in the
week the interview that andrew yang did
on cnn with jim acosta it was really bad
for andrew yang it's just like what are
the positions of the forward party it
does they're not saying them and because
it's democrats and republicans and he
says we're taking the common sense
consensus positions but he won't say
what they are
it's not forward parties not doing it
for me
focusing at the local level
and doing non-partisan local elections
i'm with you a hundred percent
i completely agree i saw that exactly
that's what i was talking about after
the german class interview yeah i got
that that's an impression from him too
now let me ask you because you you you
might know more about the forward party
than i do
is there a position they have outlined
on any specific issue
i will say that so their motto seems to
be right now that they have three
primary components on policies right so
first is representative rank choice
voting that's like their biggest thing
number two is i believe it's gun control
in some sort common sense country okay
and they have taken a significant
significant position on the election
saying that it wasn't stolen okay
it's not exactly the most courageous
thing to say one of our big pillars is
the election wasn't stolen but okay i
mean at least it's something
right i think that the entire model of
just having these three ideas and just
not setting any points at all yeah is
quite nebulous and stuff but thanks so
much for taking my call i appreciate it
my pleasure there's bodhi from new
orleans great to hear from you glad to
have the opportunity to
chat about that yeah we spoke about it
earlier and it was
it was all kind of a little weird
let's go next to dennis from newark
dennis so what is happening in beautiful
newark new jersey today
hi david can you hear me
yes i can
wonderful um
you know things uh in newark aren't too
great okay
and um in new jersey in general uh
you know things could be better
but um i'm i'm having some
really deep concerns
about the state of not necessarily the
state of democracy but just the state of
politics
um
and that's because
there's an idea that i want to propose
to you okay
it seems like
the the shift
of the political spectrum to the right
is
giving
the quote-unquote liberal media so
say msnbc
some voices
um
some republican or former republican
voices like tara set mayor sir michael
singleton
who i believe are very thoughtful um but
this is in effect
training
liberals you know actual liberals and
people left of of liberal
to view neo-liberalism as an out or to
view neo-liberals as allies against
neo-fascists
okay
i think that's really dangerous
and it's it's just going to bite us in
the butt because we tried that in the
2016 election with hillary clinton it
failed
and and so but but
the establishment just can't afford to
push us further to the left or to or let
the left lead
because they've sold out to corporations
you know so let me see if i understand
and dennis if there is a question coming
that would be great your position is
that
the center-left media like msnbc
is proposing
neoliberalism as a solution to the maga
neo-fascism
that that's already failed and that it's
not a good path forward
that's right exactly well i agree with
that
it's but
what i'm asking you is yes
i i
this is paralyzing because it's i mean
anna navarro who's a moderate republican
correct yes
is someone whom i very much admire
and
you know she but even though she's a
conservative
she's now a liberal
in the view of kind of well she's
anti-trump she's anti-trump dennis
listen i i hate to do is there a
question because do i have so many
people wanting to talk to me and we are
trying to take questions today
yes i'm i'm sorry david i
i'm i'm just i think my question is
dennis thank you i'm gonna i'm gonna go
uh okay we've gotta uh we've gotta move
on um just uh
completely uh um unable to speak there
um so overcome with emotion
let's go next to seth from san diego
seth welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
good morning david um
so a couple of oh well couple quick
questions don't worry so the first one
is um do you think
in the election liberals should take
more pride in being liberals because it
seems like a lot of these conservative
ads have like i'm a american first
conservative i'm a conservative i'm
pro-conservative trump conservative
christian conservative yeah you don't
hear anyone of that being a liberal yeah
you sometimes
i sometimes see in ads candidates will
say stuff like i'm a proud democrat and
i find it so stupid to be to be
perfectly frank
um okay i what i do think is that listen
the country is really on our side on the
issues when you look at what is that
what is the view on abortion that's most
prevalent right now
what's the view on gay marriage what's
the view on whether we should tax the
very rich to fund social program the
it's the views are of the progressives
the problem is because the progressives
don't own it in the way that you're
suggesting
it becomes disaggregated where then the
voters don't realize you kind of really
agree with the progressives and then it
becomes this vicious circle where people
shy away from the labels and then the
voters are confused and then they think
oh i should vote for a republican so i i
do agree in general with the point
you're bringing up
okay because uh i'm not sure if you're
familiar who bill maher is because
that's like my go-to
liberal right there because i feel like
he's at the very he speaks like 90
around 90 now percent of my language
there's some stuff i call them out on
which it's he's kind of stupid at times
yeah i mean bill maher you know the
thing about bill maher is he has joined
this contingent which is like the
anti-woke free speech left which is like
it's fine i agree agree with bill maher
about plenty but he's kind of fallen
into this thing of overstating the
degree to which the so-called woke left
has taken over
the movement which i think is a
relatively small degree actually
exactly like he like he exaggerates that
a lot but i was thinking because there's
you know his new roles like his rants
that he does yeah yeah it's hilarious
but there's this you know recent one
that he was talking about the
conservatives and like
you know talking about how you know they
kind of put the positive and negative in
the same ad and he's doing all that but
i was just wondering
is it do you think that
is not entirely smart because they want
to see kind of like bde you know saying
big you know i'm not sure if i can curse
on here but what you're saying is
large penis energy this sort of like
flower
stuff
big it's scientist energy yeah yeah yeah
you know that crap and so do you think
there's not a lot of that from the left
because every time whenever a liberal is
here even though the country agrees with
liberals like for example
like you know this is my own personal
opinion i'm not affiliating this with
anyone but like i'm you know currently
serving the country right now and uh
this is my own personal opinion not of
affiliating that with anything but no i
got you i i agree with you and i think
the best person so far who has said it
in a direct way is actually gavin newsom
who in an interview recently said we
need to be playing offense not defense
we need to be ruthless etc and it
doesn't mean you have to agree with him
on policy but he absolutely was
completely correct about what you're
talking about
exactly because i was on my phone and
like oh you're on cnn you're freaking
liberal and i was like
what i don't watch fox all the time you
know it's gonna say something like that
but like they look at liberals as these
naggy
you know
wussy you know [ __ ] like people but you
know and most the country agrees with
them so when you hear a conservative
he's like oh i'm you know i'm a man or
whatever the case may be which honestly
masculinity is actually better than ever
which i don't know what the hell they're
talking about
but you know i'm sorry to drag this out
for so long i was just well seth you've
really said it all and it's been a
pleasure having you on i appreciate it
of course and sorry to drag it out so
long no problem
from san diego with a very powerful
declaration
uh some things we agreed on and some
things that we did not thank you to
everyone i was able to speak to that
does it for calls today but there will
be more opportunities believe me folks
and then i hope to speak to you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show all right let's get into the
mailbag one day early because of our
slightly different schedule this week
you can email info davidpakman.com if
you have an email question comment
concern
many such examples for you today
starting with someone who's just very
very angry and i think probably has a
lot more going on personally than maybe
they mentioned in this email nathan
wrote in and nathan wrote you lie about
trump because you have no fact checking
why do you make money off your lies
so you support everything trump is for
he at least kept us safe put da's in
charge to convict drug dealers that
bring car fentanyl into our country
should be executed they are killing
innocent people knowingly that was one
sentence you want to be a true podcaster
have me as another podcaster that is
debatable to you on live every time
you're on having a podcast
even though he's not the best at the
truth necessarily you think biden has
told one truth or been transparent
nope
he said he is a middle-of-the-road
democrat
turns out he's a bigger socialist than
bernie
stop hating usa and start acting like
you live in america because either go
back to where you were and live there or
support the country you live in now
gas food crime etc what's wrong with you
at least trump can hold a speech without
forgetting where he is what he's
speaking about and understand what the
heck he is saying
support our country your standing in
these are all the wrong your by the way
you're a microphone warrior couldn't
stand up for usa troops and look at all
the problems this country has right now
just be a human not and not a dem
liberal for a minute
i'm not a republican and you're calling
republicans dumb and stupid and nuts etc
what's the matter with you
i'm bored watching you say trump's board
is pathetic
what's better than trump rally you're
making your dime off his fantasies i
don't see you covering joe biden
anything
you're impressive to want a crime-ridden
president that has not kept one single
promise and trump kept all and some
email me if you want to debate you on
your podcasts i'm definitely getting
into this line of work now that i see
your pathetic lies if i have time which
i will make time
you don't care that you're deciding to
only like half the country or more
actually with all your side coming to
the republican side and i am not
necessarily a republican but versus
biden i am he's terrible
hope you get brighter wishing you the
best
from the middle
of the road
that is apparently not a republican but
an enlightened centrist of some kind
presented with no further comment
because
i feel like i have a brain injury when i
read it greg wrote in about motive
greg said if trump stole classified
documents from the white house what
would his motive have been for
committing this crime it's a valid
question
there have been many cases of people
stealing classified government documents
do you think there's a simple
explanation like the others did he plan
to make money by selling the documents
to russia that's greg from costa rica
this is
a great question to which i have not
heard a satisfactory answer what did
trump plan to do with those documents
what did he plan to do and certainly you
know we could speculate about what greg
is writing here
but i just don't have the answer
and with trump the real answer could be
anything if you think you have an idea
what trump planned to do with the
documents
let me know because i have no clue
steve wrote in
i am so sick of hearing about the fbi
searching trump's place
being unprecedented who cares
how does something become presidented
it has to happen for a first time at
some point right the level of sheer
ignorance is beyond belief yeah i've
talked about this the fact that this has
not happened to a president before tells
us nothing about whether it's the right
or wrong thing to do whether it's legal
or illegal and whether or not trump is a
criminal
everything happens for the first time
sometime
everything that has happened
at some point was happening for the
first time
and what certainly is unprecedented is a
president that did all the things that
trump did and flouted every norm rule
and apparently even some laws
so
steve is absolutely right this entire
they've never done this to a president
before thing and therefore it must be
wrong
is logically fallacious and it certainly
doesn't pass the sniff test
next email is from lisa lisa wrote in
about the secret service in mar-a-lago
and says david is it possible that if in
fact the fbi found nothing and donald
trump safe that perhaps he was
forewarned by his loyal secret service
agents that contents of his safe were
wanted what are your thoughts yeah you
know on the night of the raid the of the
search warrant being executed i'm trying
to be more accurate about that
eric trump went on tv on fox news we
covered it live
and said there was nothing in the safe
now
he may have simply been lying
but if it's true that there was nothing
in the safe i would immediately start
wondering whether the documents were
just moved i mean it's just a completely
natural obvious question to ask
and
clearly
any investigator worth their salt like
the fbi has many of
would realize that so we don't even know
if it's true that the safe was empty
since then everybody stopped talking
about the safe was empty so it might
have been yet another lie just told on
the day of but of course if the safe is
empty
who might have warned trump and where
did they move the documents is a
perfectly reasonable question to ask
brandon wrote in about kinzinger for
president
uh kenzinger being the retiring
republican congressman adam kinzinger
who is not a pro-trump republican
brandon says dear sir as i discussed as
discussed in one of your recent shows
the democrats offer slim pickings for a
presidential candidate in the event that
biden doesn't run what about adam
kinzinger what better democrat to beat
trump or desantis than a republican's
antidote now so first of all i haven't
said that there are slim pickens i think
that there are great people
in the democratic party they aren't the
uber progressives but there are some
really good politicians in the
democratic party people are talking now
about gavin newsom i'm not like a fan of
gavin newsom but i recognize he's a very
skilled politician i think pete edged
would crush anybody in one-on-one
debates the way he's crushed his fox
news appearances i think jamie raskin is
fantastic i think john ossoff is a guy
with a bright future stacey abrams is
interesting to me i i don't think it's
slim pickens on the democratic side
that's number one number two
there are plenty of actual democrats to
choose from
i don't see why we would go with the
retiring republican
for the democratic nominee doesn't it
just doesn't make any sense to me so i
get what you're saying brandon maybe
republicans would say hey look here's a
republican but he's running as a
democrat i'll vote for him it sounds
muddled and it doesn't sound like a good
idea
trina wrote in and trina says about
right-wing trolls versus left-wing
trolls sir after seeing the beautiful
message you received containing all
those f-bombs i started to wonder how
often that happens on the other side
admittedly i don't follow many
right-wing accounts but it seems the
ratio of right-wingers trolling
left-wingers would be exponentially
larger than that of left-wingers
engaging in the same behavior i suppose
it would make sense as the right seems
far more likely to commit violence based
on political ideology but i'm curious
nonetheless are you aware
of any reputable studies on this topic
thanks for continuing to tell the truth
each day no matter who trolls you so i
don't have any studies that i was able
to find
about whether left versus right wing
trolling
of right versus left-wing content
creators
empirically has been has been quantified
i i don't know about that i can only
speak to the stuff i receive what i can
tell you is that when you look at
propensity to violence politically
motivated violence in the united states
is almost exclusively right wing
the right often will deny that they'll
say you're miscategorizing some of it
or what about antrifa
or whatever else they come up with but
the truth is that when you look at
politically motivated violence in the
united states
um if you want to find it on the left
it's the occasional what's called eco
terrorism
and it's relatively rare
the violence is mostly on the right that
we know for sure
peter wrote in and says how can i
request to be gifted a membership via
the website beautiful question
every week i get 10 emails from people
saying david
please put me on the list for a free
membership and as i've said
probably a hundred times
you can't get on the list by emailing me
you must follow these extraordinarily
simple instructions if you want a free
membership we have a waiting list it
simply goes in order
you go to davidpakman.com
slash free membership
okay peter
davidpakman.com
free membership you will be asked
your name and your email that's all we
need to get you a free membership
we currently have 800 people waiting
i know that sounds like a lot but we've
already gifted over a thousand
memberships so it actually does move
relatively quickly
um
davidpakman.com
free membership do not email me john
wrote in about due process
and john says dear mr pacman i don't
understand how people on the left
cheered about the deaths of bin laden
and al-zawahiri proper procedure would
require that they be captured alive
extradited to the u.s and tried in court
before any punishment could be imposed
no jury has seen any evidence nor heard
any legal arguments in support of any
punishment i feel that we us citizens
have been made party to an extra legal
assassination of potentially innocent
men so listen
potentially innocent i just don't buy in
the court of public opinion
these these guys are guilty of sin
but i agree with the point about due
process and i've expressed this concern
before and others on the left have as
well when i say that joe biden has an
accomplishment to his name this year
of
ordering a successful strike against
ayman al-zawahiri i don't say that as if
there's no controversy about the total
lack of due process i've mentioned it
multiple times there's a complete lack
of due process that's absolutely true
and as progressives it is right for us
to be concerned about that and i
recognize
that when you are a most wanted
terrorist
and as a president you're able to take
them out to use course language
um
that it is seen as an accomplishment so
find progressives that don't care about
the due process part but
uh i absolutely care about the due
process part of that
jock wrote in about electric cars and
says hey david i never get tired of the
republican dumb blonde joke marjorie
taylor green her rant against electric
cars was a classic the marketplace is
deciding nobody's forcing anyone to buy
an electric car if all of america
decided to drive a diesel 4x4 pickup it
would be just as bad the price of diesel
fuel would go way up pollution would go
way up but hey the oil companies would
make even more profits oh wait the dumb
blonde joke is mad about the price of
gas and diesel going up as the big oil
companies gouge poor silly margaery yeah
i don't know that we need the dumb
blonde stuff um but it is absolutely
true marjorie taylor green last week
tried to make the argument if everybody
wanted an electric car the electrical
grid wouldn't be able to keep up well
everybody can't get an electric car most
of the electric cars on the market have
waiting lists so we know what the
adoption rate could be of electric
vehicles and there's a plan in place for
the electrical grid to in parallel with
that have increased supply the point
jock makes is a really good one
if everybody switched to diesel cars
there wouldn't be enough diesel and
diesel would be astronomically priced
absolutely correct and the vendetta that
some of these people seem to have elect
against electric vehicles much of it
comes from ignorance and it comes from
political bias it just it sounds like a
sort of green new deal what aoc has a
tesla it must be bad and
it's mostly ignorance and confusion and
actually i would say ignorance and
confusion is sort of the theme of people
like marjorie taylor green
info davidpakman.com with your questions
comments and concerns we will see you on
the bonus show momentarily
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below